I mean the major problem is a fact it's
not racist class I think that America
has become an increasingly divided
around class lines and that the
disparity between rich and poor is
incredibly profound you asked me earlier
by the changes in New York I would say
the number one change in New York is the
that the rich have a lot of money and a
lot of access and the poor have very
little and that the the wrongs that you
use to pull yourself up or much more
tenuous my family is pulled up by
basically the Board of Education and
that was an institution that you went to
stayed in for X amount of years and
pulled your family up the kinds of
benefits and things that the police
department find all that kind of
municipal stuff it's really been you
know pulled back the union's don't have
the power to used to have the benefit
package is not what they used to be
insurance companies are scant are
basically I think students companies are
loan sharks I think basically a lot of
the safety net that we used to say as
part of the tapestry of this country has
been fragmented and and ripped to shreds
by Republican administrations was the
list the tacit help of weak wield
Democrats and so we have a country a
city new york and a country word it is
increasingly hard to get to get ahead
and i really believe that to me its
class race to me is a as a tool to
divide people i don't really think that
the i really think to be Chinese
immigrant and the black kid from the
from the hood and the Latino and
south-central have a lot more comment
and they think in terms of trying to get
ahead but race is a real good tool not
to let them get together and I think
it's been manipulated and still have
manipulated both by white power
structure keep people separate and by
politicians and power brokers in these
various communities who can use race as
a leverage to build their own power
bases if you separate working-class
black people
citylight Brooklyn and you have them at
odds over power you're not really
focusing on the larger issues to me so I
that's what that I think the right class
is increasingly we're becoming more like
England and I really feel profoundly
that this class thing is a huge part of
it I mean I just use many more clubs
when New York was a vibrant cultural
City and I say vibe I mean not a city
that consumes culture which is what it
does now but creates culture which it
doesn't do nearly as well there was a
lot more democracy there was not table
sir bottle service is a really
interesting the idea bottle service
really is a profound idea in that you
can only sit down if you're buying dumb
or Cristal or whatever and if you're not
you can't sit down what the is that
you know you think about what that says
if you don't have a lot of money you
can't really sit down in this club we
can barely get enemy but you certainly
can't sit down here so usually clip let
you go in and you sat down you could sit
anywhere you could it would maybe in the
little VIP section but it there was a
kind of democracy of the room democracy
is no democracy of the room anymore and
in fact people pay big money not to be
the Democratic at clubs I think the
American identity is I mean there was
always a falsehood about it but it's
definitely graphically so when people
talk about hip-hop they always say well
it's so materialistic and so once what
who in america isn't materialistic wait
a minute you mean effect that they want
a big car they want expensive jewelry
and they want big houses and beautiful
women how is that when did that become
an American I I don't think the guys I
see out at bungalow 8 and the kids at
soho house and those guys I they got
suits on as soon as they take they
loosen a tie and suspenders come out
they want the fine girl they want a
big-ass car they want a big-ass house
and it weren't a very expensive watch so
you know to me it's just a matter of
degrees of greed countries founded on
greed and it's becoming more greedy all
the time